Check out this week's must see movies!
My next show is gonna be... drumroll please.. A SINGING COMPETITION!
From the creators of Despicable Me comes Sing.
An animated comedy about the biggest town competition to rock the animal kingdom!
Is he asking me on a date?
She didn't seem that impressed.
Passengers is an epic Sci-Fi Action Romance about two space travelers awakened 90 years to soon.
There's a reason we woke up early.
I understand it's your birthday.
The party is just getting started.
In the fantasy film Assassin's Creed
A criminal must enter the memories of an ancient ancestor to discover his destiny.
Here's this week's Fanticipation.
So what's your weekend to get going to be? Let us know by commenting below.
See you next time on Weekend Ticket.